was it a honeymoon couple on a plane
yeah there's a couple
they were on a honeymoon and the plane
hadn't yet taken off and the um
the the woman who had just gotten
married
uh just became violently and horribly
ill on the plane i mean it was
not like a pretty little like sick bag
kind of thing it was just like
i'm going to paint with my organs like
it was just
crazy and people were freaking out all
over the plane and
there so they brought a stretcher down
and they put her on the stretcher and
they're
wheeling her away and like the the uh
her her new husband is just kind of
cruising along with the thing and he
sees me and he's like
deadpool no way high five and
i
you know like you know like he's like
let's touch eyeballs
no no and by the way your wife is like
half dead
help her man so it's just a very surreal
moment i'm
i'm sure they're fine i'm sure they're
on their second uh anniversary now yeah
just kicking it somewhere that's such an
embarrassing thing happened to me
yesterday
on the tube so is it i've obviously got
like oh anyway right basically what
happened more
so i stood on oxford tube platform yeah
and i've always got
um so you know like a glass keep cup you
know like
rather than going to a coffee shop and
getting a new cup i i carry a glass one
that i then wash
and re-get my latte and
and so i got i got me empty cup and i
just stood
down and stuff and an elderly gentleman
was walking towards me on the platform
and i was just uh god i'm i just i just
want to get on the tube i hate getting
recognized
he started to walk towards me but then
he had his arm out and his arm
came in some space and on the tube on
the platform it's crowded and it's a bit
i don't know i just got the kind of
light oh what are you doing a bit
aggressive unnecessarily and actually
what he was doing
was he went oh sorry i thought you
wanted money and he was trapped
[Applause]
oh i just like sat there
and i was like someone make eye contact
so i can tell this story i was like
understand i was like now we've got a
really good story
because dwayne presumably you can't hide
you can't put a hat
i've seen you in a gym like a public
gym so do you get to get bothered all
the time all the time
yes but how do you feel out the window
how do you work out in the gym if people
are constantly giving up to you
uh just be nice say hello get them
moving get the movie lift them
but fame is a funny thing right so that
story for you well that will be like the
constant anchoring reminder right of
like how cool fame is but also
never like i don't have the stress you
have though because
i think the thing is if you if you are
five or six and you've got a hat on and
you're dressed like a most the time a
teenage boy in a baseball cap
headphones on head down i catch the bus
and i catch the bus on the subway
every single day because i'm not in
anyone's eye line like that but i
imagine you there is something about
if if you're you you can't you're not
you're seven feet tall so yeah but
kevin's
kevin's had weird you've had weird fans
what happens if you're three foot two
like that
how do you do it what are you talking
about
no how do you deal with that you know
that hey
i don't think well first there's two
we're we're skipping around some points
here
first thing she's saying she's dressed
like a teenage boy
that for somebody to put money in your
cup it's got to be a lot worse than that
something within your parents said i
need to help this person
make sure they eat today something
happens uh for me
i mean it's it's bad um and
because i'm a big deal uh it's
it's just it's it's the guy followed was
in a restaurant where he followed you oh
my god
i had uh i had a guy actually follow me
into uh
uh the bathroom was a true story i'm in
a stall
you know i gotta go and you know yeah
while i'm in the bathroom is that kevin
can i get a picture and i'm like you
know cause i'm obviously a
very big guy i i stand up for myself
immediately i say hey
not in here you wait until i'm done okay
so you go outside
i take it with you when i get outside um
and i go on the stall you close the door
and you know you would expect whoever
that was to
have left they're gone and i you know i
do what i got to do and it was a
it was one of those situations where i
had to be in there for a while
you know i'm in there uh and you know
literally you know when you when you get
comfortable you start to take your time
and
i'm on my phone i'm scrolling i'm you
know it's just it's a
it's a it's a comfortable inventory what
you do with the mall that's it
i get done and i like
get out the stall and close the door
he's right there
can we get the picture i was like i
meant outside the bathroom man
out the bathroom i'm not taking a
picture with you in the bathroom but the
fact that he stood there like
very nicely the whole time it made me
feel obligated and i was like hey just
just come on selfie
real quick don't tell nobody you saw me
in here
friends with jason statham every day
but i'm distracted by the makings of a
cocktail
oh yes it's a cocktail at christmas
everyone yeah
shall i yes please now what okay well i
like to give britain a little tip every
now and again so you need to find
yourself a sheath
right now this is just a minute hold on
hold on
i don't know if i want that drink if you
go to the really posh cocktail bars you
get these incredible
ice cubes that they hand carve oh no no
no we go get a water bomb
right and we just split it and we peel
it off and we get a lovely
round bear with me bear with me this is
what they do in the posh places then
we're gonna
make a christmas negroni
i think of myself as a christmas negroni
[Applause]
um so negroni i want you to think of it
as medicine right okay
if you've got every one of us has
someone a bit boring a bit sort of dodgy
coming to the christmas party there's
always one so then what you do
is you take this negroni aka medicine
medicine right
and it turns people that are a bit
problematic and boring mm-hmm
into interesting people whoa so
is twenty trying to say know
and he's pouring three drinks
this is uh 20 meals of campari
20 mils of vermouth rosso which we've
scented
uh with a little cinnamon and christmas
fair yes
and then we have a little gin a little
bit of clementine to get you going
are you ready for this i'm like come on
man now
once you said this if if you don't
become more interesting i don't know
what's going to happen
okay okay he's going okay lovely
one pass it down it's like school yeah
go home we have four we have four we
have four
no no where are we cheers merry
christmas merry christmas
this is a bit like a christmas carol and
we are scrooge because like
merry christmas everybody it's like 600
tiny tims
okay oh come on come on
oh that is just how come the world's
changing although not being a judge of
whether or not it's delicious
no i like that it has just enough
christmas in it here's the thing
no that's very good that's right you
wanna sit you wanna sit hold up
here we go oh i drank from this side so
you can drink from that side you can
drink from the other side
you gotta get it you know you see what
you think is this like feeding a gremlin
after midnight how's that
that's good that's good
[Applause]
cocktail
yeah a christmas to remember
that was the christmas oh
the underwater sequence yeah yes uh
that looked hard oh dear that was that
was pretty difficult it was a
really technical probably about a week
at pinewood um
because we shot film here uh in in
london and it was all under water it's a
sequence where this sphere
falls off a cliff and she and another
actor by the name of justice are stuck
inside of the sphere
and i'm on the outside of the sphere
trying to rescue them as it sinks and
uh water is filling up the gyrosphere
and at one point we're completely
submerged in water and
yeah we we spent what i don't know uh a
week or eight days or nine days we spent
in water yeah and it was
boy i'll tell you they put a lot of
chlorine in the water because you've got
a crew of 85 people
just pissing this pool like
no one ever got it no no no no no people
we didn't have time for people to pee
so you knew people were peeing oh i'm
certain though
people would suddenly just
i don't have senses that was good
that's a good yeah i don't mind doing
that again
yeah she just made me tinkle a little
bit
because it made sense yeah i tinkled a
little bit when you
i mean it you pee you're not supposed to
pee in the pool but no one got out
and and i know cause i was i had to be
underwater
with my eyes open of course uh as if i
could see with my eyes open under water
chris did you pee i actually
[ __ ] myself
time is money on a movie like this
chris you were in the water
well i was trapped in this gyrosphere
right your defense
it makes sense
i just felt this freedom as i was
working you know what i mean
i just was like really present um
you didn't feed claire p yes
claire claire was panicked
yeah every time you've said that for the
last like seven months i'm like
i wasn't happy i'm just so deeply
ashamed
um and that's when we team up and we
sort of become best buds
on and off screen
[Laughter]
and uh and we fight these elemental
creatures
this but now filming together like jake
tom it sounds like was quite
unsympathetic to you while you were
filming when would didn't you get a
little
a little peaky oh well uh yeah we were
shooting
well we were shooting a scene and i uh
i got a i got i i got sick i i i
was very nauseous throughout the day and
and in the middle of the
one of the takes i i i threw up
in the middle of the take and uh kept
going you know but that's how that's
what acting's all about
i was sitting opposite him and i was
like how is he doing that
he is so good he looks so tortured and
so unwell and so
and so like like hurt and then he
basically just had a stomach bug
and they actually cgied the vomit out of
the shot but if you look in the movie
in the movie my mouth is just partially
open at one i'm kidding
[Applause]
you know
[Music]